all right top 10 worst list time and you
know what that means God who sure that's
darker than light blue shirt but it's
still blue but it's dark which almost
means it's bad but it's not alright here
is the list of the top 10 worst movies
of 2011 and just like the top 10 best
list I didn't see everything that came
out in 2011 so I'm sure there's a couple
movies that would be on here had I seen
them but I didn't and there were a lot
of movies that deserve to be on this
list that came out in 2011 rest assured
there will be a few that should be on
here but they just can't be 10 slots and
all however if it really perplexes you
you should probably make a top 10 worst
list of 2011 video that's what all the
cool kids are doing enough babbling here
we go the mood Ted all right so this
movie started the year off with a bang
so I'm gonna start my video off with
this movie season of the witch right so
Nicolas Cage has done some movies
in his lifetime no one's arguing that
now he's done season of the witch this
tried to be some medieval epic or
something like that turns out it's just
a generic movie with his generic
characters on their generic quest in the
generic movie of generic it's not good
at all
9 ever see about 25 lead characters mean
nothing do nothing and be nothing in a
movie yeah so VII it's called New Year's
Eve the movies called New Year's Eve the
movies about New Year's Eve and the
movie wasn't in theaters long enough to
even make it to New Year's Eve yeah
probably a misstep right there a
character-based movie with characters
that just don't matter that's like
having an entire main course of a meal
be a big block of tofu not smart and not
good number AIDS Kevin James I know
you're funny I know you can be funny
I've seen you funny I've laughed at the
funny things that you've done and said
and then you started doing theatrical
movies then you did zookeeper this is a
low point in Kevin James's career and
somehow they got Nick Nolte to voice a
gorilla
luckily Nick Nolte has warrior to fall
back on Kevin James has a show that was
canceled a few years ago funny show not
enough number 7 the unofficial vampire
sequel to Legion now it got priest Paul
Bettany I don't know what this dude's
deal is he was like I just want to do
generic crappy movies in which I play a
priest or a holy figure of some kind as
long as the movies not good I am down
with it let's sign the paperwork I'll
give this movie a couple things one it
was exactly what I thought the movie
would be from the trailer and Meggie cue
because she's just hot and I'm giving
the movie that OH
other than that nothing number six
all right we've all had a creepy-ass
roommate that we would just rather
forget again a generic ass movie in
which this small mousy unstable girls
are supposed to be threatening or
something yeah cam last name I can't
pronounce is gonna be threatened by this
chick that makes a perfect amount of
sense this movie wasn't just bad it was
it was horrible this movie was one of
those movies when I was making this list
I forgot about that movie and Tyler and
I was like oh yeah there's that movie
this has to be on there it's like all
the negative of having a creepy unstable
chick roommate without any of the perks
that might come with that situation five
all right we all love Alexander Dumont
at a point we like three musketeer
movies then at a point they just started
becoming bad and then worse three
musketeers all right Paul WS Anderson
directed this movie as a lotta you
probably know I'm not a big fan of his
at all I enjoyed the first Mortal Kombat
pretty much nothing else after that it's
like he was like all right studio here's
the pitch I'm gonna make a three
musketeers movie and I'm not gonna give
a about it and the lowest flow of
this movie is that Christoph vaults is
in it man how that guy could win an
Oscar oh yeah he did and he's pretty
much done nothing worth remembering
after that Oh
all right we have D boxes a gimmick we
have 3d as a gimmick now we have
aromascope as a gimmick Spy Kids 40 all
the time in the world I understand this
movie's made for kids so it's not
supposed to appeal to adults but when
you have Jeremy Piven and Joel McHale in
this shitty movie and they're horrible
in it that's bad enough but then when
you have some stupid gimmick that's like
all the baby is diaper here smell
the scratch-and-sniff thing I'm like no
I'm why would I do that now this movie
actually just angered me by concept and
execution there's no way it wasn't going
to be on this list don't see this all
right so this movie came out on Friday I
saw it on Monday so there was an entire
weekend in which people were like dude
this is the worst movie ever and I was
like it's gotta be over hide the horrid
nature this movie's got to be over hyped
by now but it wasn't Conan the Barbarian
was every bit as bad as I had heard it
was other than the fact this movie
doesn't take off until about 30 minutes
into the movie editing is all over the
place like the things happen like this
mountains crumbling around everyone then
it's not then it is again they're like
oh let's have the barbarian from Game of
Thrones and the bad guy from Avatar and
throw them in a movie with
was McGowan and it'll all be good no
it'll be exactly what you think it's
going to be number two all right just
like a top ten best list these next two
number one and two can interchange but
I've put them in this order for a good
reason number two is actually the
Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part one the
Twilight Saga has trucked along and is
built up to this this the worst of the
movies nothing happens in this movie
it's like New Year's Eve with one third
the actors but at least dogs talk to
each other with psychic powers what this
would have been number one had another
movie not come out this year Twilight
Saga Breaking Dawn Part 1 during
honorary number one in my book as Yoda
once said there is another no mo one
all right the movie that actually made
me angry I was sitting there and this
movie just infuriated me I was like I'm
done this I'm I'm done Jack and Jill the
reason this movie pissed me off so much
is that Adam Sandler has been funny in
his life there was a time in the 90s
Adam Sandler was just a funny dude he
made funny movies holy look here most of
them yeah but then there was wedding
singer and that was good really good
actually so I know what he's capable of
and he's just declined to the point
where Jack and Jill then came out and I
was like done I'm done with this guy and
I wanted to make this number two because
Al Pacino was in it I was like he did
provide a couple of funny lines in the
movie but in the end that's one of the
saddest aspects of this movie Al Pacino
is in it I don't know what Adam Sandler
was told by Satan to get this movie
greenlit but somehow it happened you
know that's what it is the devil himself
came to Adam Sandler was like all right
Jeremy's gonna make a top 10 worst list
of 2011 can you make a worse movie than
Twilight and here we are good job
Twilight Satan saved you so those are my
picks for the top 10 worst movies of
2011 what are your picks comment below
let me know make a video about it put it
as a video response go crazy when I do
these lists like this I can't wait to
see what the next year brings 2012 but I
can only imagine and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you